This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一档I-Heart播客。真人真事。在每个陪伴孩子准备午餐的夜晚背后，都充满了悬念。他们会吃掉蔬菜吗？帕斯塔面能在第一口后幸存吗？饭盒带回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.za for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the survivor files.
而且，你能在切完黄瓜之前看完第八集吗？选择Bell纯光纤网络，尊享Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94元起。两年期网络套餐加自动扣款信用额度，价格两年不变。访问bell.za了解详情并查询覆盖情况。Bell，连接意味着一切。我九个月的囚禁生活幸存下来，我用一生探索其他人是如何从本该毁灭他们的绝境中生还的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是《幸存者档案》。
Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought. opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed.
每周，我都和那些经历过难以想象之事的幸存者在一起：遭遇绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺声音。这些故事讲的是如何付出一切活著走出来。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方，收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的性格同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一档每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等深度探讨的人。每周，我们与你最喜欢的作家、BookTok创作者以及满满的深度思考一起，将书籍、网络和流行文化串联起来。是的，我入迷了。
I'm obsessed. Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space.
我入迷了。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方，收听《Pro Society》。我是霍达·科特布，播客《霍达·科特布的100%快乐》的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒向有志演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提出的建议一样。你被雇佣不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。
You're hired to fill the space. with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody, I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology.
你被雇佣是为了用你来填满空间。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方，收听霍达·科特布的《霍达·科特布的100%快乐》。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的帅哥邀请我坐他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮涅罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的私密空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方，收听《Solita》。大家好，我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档探讨我们二十岁时的最大改变、重要时刻与人生过渡，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. Thank you for joining me. Wherever you are in the world, it is very great to have you here. Today, I have another bonus episode for you. If you are new to this corner of the podcast in our bonus episodes, we basically fact check and myth bust psychology concepts that you may have heard kind of swirling around the internet a little bit. And we basically provide you with the real research, the real history, and the real history and the real science behind what they mean. We've done personality tests, we've done Stockholm syndrome, narcissism, Maslow's hierarchy of needs, so many things. But today we are turning our sights and our attention to shadow work. Shadow work is a practice that is focused on what we call
大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。感谢大家的加入。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴有你在这里。今天，我为你们准备了另一期额外节目。如果你是这个播客角落的新朋友，在我们的额外节目中，我们基本上会去验证和打破一些你可能在网络上听过的心理学概念的迷思。我们基本上会为你提供这些概念背后的真实研究、真实历史以及真实科学。我们探讨过人格测试、斯德哥尔摩综合征、自恋、马斯洛需求层次理论，等等诸多内容。但今天，我们将目光和注意力转向阴影工作。阴影工作是一种专注于我们所谓的
the shadow self or just the shadow and how this part of us influences our behavior unconsciously. If you have ever done any kind of psychotherapy or psychoanalysis, you're probably very familiar with this concept or idea. But it's become exceedingly popular in recent years as people have kind of been searching for deeper ways of meeting and knowing themselves. This approach is definitely an interesting one because it kind of promises a good deal of epiphanies and it really promises the possibility of suddenly uncovering some really deep truths about why you are the way you are and, you know, who you are. And, you know, for a lot of us,
阴影自我或仅仅是阴影，以及这一部分如何无意识地影响我们行为的实践。如果你做过任何形式的心理治疗或精神分析，你可能对这个概念或想法非常熟悉。但近年来它变得异常流行，因为人们一直在寻找更深层次的方式来认识和了解自己。这种方法绝对很有趣，因为它承诺会带来大量的顿悟，并且确实承诺有可能突然揭开一些关于你为什么会成为现在的你、以及（你知道的）你是谁的深层真相。而且，（你知道的）对我们许多人来说，
that's comforting that there's this thing out there that can suddenly reveal why we self-sabotage, why we act in the way that we do. But I think you also should be prepared to find out some stuff you might not want to know about who you are. So let's break down just what shadow work really entails from the most basic principles to some of the more advanced practices. So I think the first thing you should know is what the shadow actually is. I gave a brief explanation, but the shadow essentially represents the aspects of yourself that you don't like and that you don't want to be associated with and therefore find it very difficult to acknowledge and recognize. The first thing you should know about shadow work is who created it. That's a great
这是一种安慰，有这样一种东西可以突然揭示我们为什么自我破坏、为什么会有现在的行为。但我也认为，你应该做好准备，去发现一些你可能并不想知道的关于你是谁的东西。所以让我们来剖析一下阴影工作真正包含的内容，从最基础的原则到一些更高级的实践。所以我想你首先应该知道的是阴影到底是什么。我做了个简短的解释，但阴影本质上代表了你身上那些你不喜欢、不想与之产生关联、因此觉得很难去承认和辨认的方面。你应该了解的关于阴影工作的首要事情是：是谁创造了它？这是一个很好的
place to start. The idea came from Carl Jung, who we have been mentioning a lot recently. So if you're a frequent listener, I'm sorry, but also I don't know how much to revisit for the basics, but simply, Carl Jung was a Swiss psychiatrist. He was a psychoanalyst, and he developed analytical psychology, which is the school of psychological thought, which is very much focused on the unconscious mind. and the realization of our true self through a lifelong process that he called individuation. Now, Jung's approach was very deep, it was very inward focused, it was very much concerned with symbols and dreams, and he had a lot of similarities to Freud. I say similarities, he actually originally trained under Sigmund Freud, the grandfather of
切入点。这个想法来自卡尔·荣格，我们最近经常提到他。所以如果你是一个老听众，我很抱歉，但我也拿不准复习基础知识该讲多少，不过简单来说，卡尔·荣格是一位瑞士精神病学家。他是一名精神分析学家，他创立了分析心理学，这是一个非常专注于无意识心理的心理学流派，并且通过他称之为个体化的一生过程来实现我们真正的自我。现在，荣格的方法非常深邃，非常注重内省，高度关注象征和梦境，他与弗洛伊德有很多相似之处。我说相似，其实他最初师从于现代心理学的祖师爷
modern psychology, and you'll know that if you listen to our Freud episode. and at the time he was kind of considered his successor. You know, the baton was going to be passed from Jung, oh, sorry, from Freud to Jung. But they eventually parted ways professionally and personally they had these series of major disagreements. They had beef, as we would say in the modern day. Beef is probably an understatement.
西格姆·弗洛伊德，如果你听过我们的弗洛伊德单集，你就会知道这一点，当时他被认为是他的继承人。你知道的，接力棒将从荣格，哦，抱歉，从弗洛伊德传给荣格。但他们最终在职业和个人上分道扬镳，他们经历了一系列重大的分歧。用我们现代人的话来说，他们之间有过节。说有过节可能都有些保守了。
The way they expressed these disagreements was that they would write these like research papers and these articles and acting magazines and journals back and forth and back and forth obviously about the other one, about the other person. And the reason for this disagreement was that Freud was also focused on the unconscious mind, but he was very much focused on sexual and aggressive impulses. And he saw the unconscious largely as this place where there was repressed material from early childhood that we had to to dig at. And Jung kind of agreed in some ways. He said the unconscious mind was important. There were definitely things there that we couldn't access. But he thought that the
他们表达这些分歧的方式是，他们会互相撰写研究论文、文章，在各大杂志和期刊上针锋麦。芒，一来一回，显然都是针对对方的。而产生这种分歧的原因在于，弗洛伊德同样专注于无意识心理，但他高度关注性和攻击性冲动。他主要将无意识视为早期童年时期被压抑材料的聚集地，我们需要去挖掘它们。而荣格在某种程度上表示赞同。他说无意识心理很重要。那里确实存在我们无法触及的东西。但他认为，
idea that a lot of those impulses were sexual or aggressive was too narrow. You know, he really wanted to expand this idea and he wanted to talk about symbols and religion and myths and dreams and what he called the collective unconscious. The collective unconscious was this. idea that beyond our own individual unconscious, there is a deeper level, a deeper layer of shared psychological patterns that all humans inherit. And these patterns show up across cultures, across time, across history, and he labeled them as the archetypes. So the archetypes, this is the first critical thing you need to understand if you want to get into shadow work, are these instinctual patterns that are common amongst.
很多这些冲动属于性冲动或攻击性冲动的这种观点过于狭隘了。你知道的，他真的很想扩展这个概念，他想谈论象征、宗教、神话、梦境，以及他所谓的集体无意识。集体无意识就是这样一种观念：在我们各自独立的无意识之外，还存在着一个更深层次、更深层的共享心理模式，这是所有人类都继承的。这些模式跨越文化、跨越时间、跨越历史地呈现出来，他将它们标记为原型。因此，原型——如果你想涉足阴影工作，这是你需要理解的第一个关键事物——是存在于
every single culture, every single human across history. He basically believed that we all have this built-in psychological software or psychological patterns that shape the human mind and shape the human experience. For example, every single human has the self, which brings all of our personality together. Every single human has a shadow, which we're talking about today. They have a persona, which is what they kind of use to cover up the parts of themselves that they don't like. And then there's something called the anima and the animus, which we're going to reserve for a whole separate episode. Now, those are the four components of like the unconscious mind,
每一个单一文化、每一个历经历史的人类之中的本能模式。他基本上相信，我们所有人都内置了这种心理软件或心理模式，它们塑造了人类的心智和人类的体验。例如，每个人都有自我，它将我们所有的个性凝聚在一起。每个人都有一个阴影，也就是我们今天要谈论的内容。他们有一个人格面具（Persona），这是他们用来掩盖自己不喜欢的部分的伪装。然后还有一种叫做阿尼玛（Anima）和阿尼姆斯（Animus）的东西，我们将留到单独的一整期节目中再讲。好了，这些是无意识心灵的四个组成部分，
basically not the unconscious mind, but our architecture as humans, as feeling humans. And then there are these additional aspects which are called the archetypes. And this is how each of these different parts, is channeled. So the archetypes are the templates or patterns that shape how we experience certain roles or themes in our lives. So the common ones that you might hear people talk about include the caregiver, the hero, the jester, the lover, the ruler, the rebel. This is actually where personality tests like Maya Briggs come from. If you've ever done a personality test
基本上不是无意识心灵，而是我们作为人类、作为有感知的个体的架构。然后还有这些被称为原型的附加方面。这就是这些不同部分如何被引导的方式。因此，原型是塑造我们如何体验生活中某些角色或主题的模板或模式。所以你可能会听到人们谈论的常见原型包括照顾者、英雄、小丑、情人、统治者、叛逆者。这其实就是像迈尔斯-布里格斯（MBTI）这样的人格测试的来源。如果你做过人格测试，
and it's given you a, you know, four-letter acronym that is meant to describe everything about who you are, know that this came from Jung and his work with archetypes and the shadows. So you've encountered the theory before. But each of these archetypes, and I gave you a couple, you know, the hero, the jester, etc., they each seek something different and they have a different role in society and for us personally. Their role is either to provide structure, to connect to others to leave a mark or to provide wisdom. Within that, each archetype then seeks something and embodies this role as a way to obtain the thing it seeks. So for example, the ruler archetype creates order in society and what they really deep down want as a ruler is control. They really need control
并且它给出了一个四个字母的缩写，意在描述你的一切，要知道这来自于荣格及其对原型和阴影的研究。所以你以前其实接触过这个理论。但这些原型——我给你们举了几个例子，比如英雄、小丑等——它们各自寻求不同的东西，并在社会以及我们个人身上扮演着不同的角色。它们的作用要么是提供结构、与他人连接、留下印记，要么是提供智慧。在此之内，每个原型都会寻求某种东西，并以这种方式将这个角色具象化，以获得它所寻求的东西。例如，统治者原型在社会中创造秩序，作为统治者，他们内心深处真正想要的是控制权。他们真的需要控制权
to feel psychologically safe. The outlaw is another archetype and they really need liberation. So they seek liberation through everything that they do. The every man seeks belonging. The artist seeks innovation. We typically lean towards one and we see these archetypes in nearly every society and they play out again and again and again. However, we can shift between them. We lean towards one, but we shift between them. So if you have what Jung would call like a healthy, mature personality, you could be and you could embody the ruler when you were leading a project, but you could also embody the caregiver when you are comforting a friend. You could embody the explorer when you are travelling. Now, each of these archetypes has kind of a light expression, which is like the general
为了感到心理上的安全。亡命之徒是另一个原型，他们真正需要的是解放，因此他们在所做的一切中都在寻求解放。平凡大众寻求归属感。艺术家寻求创新。我们通常倾向于其中一种原型，并且我们在几乎每个社会中都能看到这些原型，它们一遍又一遍地上演。然而，我们可以在它们之间转换。我们倾向于某一个，但我们会在它们之间转换。所以如果你拥有荣格所说的健康、成熟的人格，你在领导一个项目时可以成为并体现统治者，但当你在安慰朋友时，你也可以体现照顾者。当你在旅行时，你可以体现探险家。现在，这些原型中的每一个都有某种光明的一面，也就是一般的表现方式。
way that they present. But there is also a shadow expression that develops when the role becomes over-identified with and when we become obsessed with what our archetype seeks. And it's then the role of the persona to kind of cover up how it goes about seeking them in these kind of darker parts of ourselves. So the caregiver, for example, in its lighter form, is about compassion and support and generosity and looking after others. But when it becomes ego driven, it can turn into overgiving, people pleasing, codependency, needing to be needed in order to feel worthy. The shadow side then takes a step further and can involve resentment, using care as a way to gain approval or power,
但同时也会有一种阴暗面，当这个角色被过度认同，当我们沉迷于我们原型所追求的东西时，阴暗面就会产生。这时，人格面具的作用就是去掩盖它是如何在我们的这些黑暗面中去追求这些东西的。举个例子，照顾者在光明的一面时，代表着同情、支持、慷慨和照顾他人。但当它受到自我驱动时，就会演变成过度付出、讨好他人、共生依赖，需要被需要来证明自己的价值。阴暗面则会更进一步，可能包含怨恨，把照顾当作获得认可或权力的手段，
needing control through caring for others. And that shadow side is the stuff that we don't want to acknowledge when we speak about ourselves as a caring person. We don't want to acknowledge, and we rarely will acknowledge how that behavior and that desire can sometimes become ugly. I'll give you another example. The hero archetype is another one that you might. hear about a lot.
通过照顾他人来获取控制欲。而这种阴暗面，正是当我们以关爱他人的人自居时，不愿承认的东西。我们不愿承认，也极少会承认这种行为和欲望有时会变得多么丑陋。我再给你举个例子。英雄原型是另一个你可能会经常听到的原型。
In its outward facing form, it's about courage, it's about growth and facing challenges. But when this becomes ego-driven, it can turn into needing to prove ourselves, constantly pushing, seeing everything as a battle that we have to win. And the shadow side of that shows up as arrogance, hyper-competitiveness, maybe hurting others or an inability to ask for help. The final one I should talk about, I'm going to give one more example. I feel like examples are the best way to make this known is the jester. Now the jester brings humour and lightness and connection,
在其外显的形式中，它关乎勇气、成长和面对挑战。但当它被自我驱动时，可能会变成需要证明自己，不断逼迫自己，把每件事都看作是一场必须赢的战斗。而它的阴暗面则表现为傲慢、过度竞争、可能伤害他人或无法开口寻求帮助。最后一个我应该谈谈的原型，我再举一个例子。我觉得举例是让人们了解这一点的最好方式，那就是小丑。现在，小丑带来了幽默、轻松和连结，
but when it becomes a rigidly fixed identity, it can turn into deflecting everything with jokes, avoiding vulnerability, needing to be liked at all times. And then the shadow side of this might include deep insecurity, using humor aggressively, deep, deep loneliness that we don't want to look at. These behaviors where we try and cover up this deeper side of us are the persona.
但当它变成一种死板固定的身份时，就会变成用笑话岔开所有话题、逃避脆弱、时刻需要获得别人的喜爱。而它的阴暗面可能包括深深的不安全感、攻击性地使用幽默、以及我们不愿直视的深深的孤独。这些我们试图用来掩盖内层面的行为，就是人格面具。
The persona acts as a psychological protective mask that kind of covers up this raw, unfiltered, often maybe socially unacceptable part of us, which lives in the shadow. Our persona is what reflects what we think and we or we know we ought to be doing. It reflects our societal expectations and norms. and who we kind of wish we could be that we know we are not. So those are the components of the shadow. And really at the end of the day, the shadow is like,
人格面具就像是一张心理保护面具，它掩盖了我们内心这种原始的、未经过滤的、可能在社会上无法被接受的部分，而这部分就住在阴影里。我们的人格面具反映了我们认为自己应该做的事情，或者是我们知道自己应该做的事情。它反映了社会的期望和规范，以及那种我们希望自己能成为、但深知自己并非如此的理想自我。这些就是阴影的组成部分。说到底，阴影就像是，
is the kind of stuff you keep in the basement. And it's important to know that doesn't necessarily mean all these things are horrible and evil and awful. It's, I don't know, it's just the parts of yourself that you don't want to see, including parts that could actually be quite great. we all have this we all you meet your mom your dad your sister your brother your cousin we have a shadow and it's we've shoved away parts of ourselves that we don't think will be accepted and that we aren't
就像是你藏在地下室里的那种东西。需要知道的是，这并不意味着所有这些东西都一定是可怕的、邪恶的、糟糕的。它只是，我不知道，它只是你不想看到的你身上的那些部分，包括那些实际上可能相当不错的成分。我们所有人都有这个，你遇到你的妈妈、爸爸、姐姐、弟弟、表亲，我们都有阴影，我们把那些我们认为不会被接受、并且我们自己也不愿意接受的自我部分推开、隐藏了起来。
willing to accept there's also something that we should mention which is the collective shadow this is like the dark side of society this is the stuff that opposes our shared values that we don't want to acknowledge exists but does it is revenge it is violence it is the need for power it is deep suffering and atrocities. We wish society wasn't like this. We have some deep hope that maybe society will one day not be like this, but we also know that this is just part of human behavior, where there is light, there is also darkness, where there is good in humanity, there is also bad, and that is the shadow. That is the evil of society that we don't want to look at either. So that's the critical kind of core stuff you should know. Returning to the personal shadow,
还有一点我们应该提及，那就是集体阴影。这就像社会的黑暗面，这是那些违背我们共同价值观、我们不愿承认其存在但确实存在的东西。它是复仇，是暴力，是对权力的需求，是深重的痛苦和暴行。我们希望社会不是这个样子的。我们怀揣着一种深切的希望，也许社会有一天会不再是这个样子，但我们也知道，这就是人类行为的一部分，有光的地方就有暗，人性中有善也有恶，这就是阴影。这也是我们同样不愿正视的社会的邪恶面。所以，这些就是你应该了解的关键核心内容。回到个人阴影，
how does it develop and how can it or how can they present? So it's important to think about your childhood self here and think, or just think about a child in general. Children, we have this wide range of emotions and needs and impulses and behaviors. And when we're young, we experience these in like the rawest, most purest form. You know, when you're angry, you're angry. When you're jealous, when you're tired, you're tired. we want control, we want attention, we want love. As we grow up, we learn that this isn't
它是如何形成的？它又是如何表现的？所以在这一点上，思考你童年时的自己是很重要的，去想想自己，或者泛指一个孩子。孩子们拥有广泛的情绪、需求、冲动和行为。当我们年幼时，我们以最原始、最纯粹的形式体验这些。你知道，当你生气时，你就是生气。当你嫉妒时，当你累了时，你就是累了。我们想要控制，想要关注，想要爱。当我们长大后，我们了解到这并不
entirely acceptable and that it won't necessarily make people like us. So we suppress organic reactions in favor of belonging and acceptance. Now over time, we split ourselves into the part of us that keeps us safe and accepted by the group and attached to society. And the other part of us that is ugly and would rather remain unseen. And there's what we see is our, or what we know is our true self. It's probably not, but we feel like this awful evil part of us that nobody should ever see is our true self, so we should keep it out of sight and out of mind. The thing is, is that just because we try to disown these parts of ourselves does not mean they cease to exist. That is a tale as old as time. Those parts of yourself that you don't like, the just
完全被社会所接受，并且这不一定会让别人喜欢我们。因此，为了获得归属感和认可，我们压抑了自己本能的反应。随着时间的推移，我们将自己分裂成两部分：一部分让我们在群体中保持安全、被接纳并与社会保持连结；另一部分则是丑陋的、宁愿不见天日的自我。而我们所看到的，或者我们所认知的真实的自己，其实可能并不是真正的自己。但我们觉得这部分可怕、邪恶、任何人都不应见到的自己才是真实的自我，所以我们应该眼不见心不烦。问题在于，仅仅因为我们试图抛弃这些自我部分，并不意味着它们就不复存在了。这是一个古老的故事。那些你不喜欢的自我部分，嫉妒、
jealousy, the anger, the selfishness, like they're still there. It's like energy in a way. It can't be destroyed. It can only be converted. And this part of ourself converts in unexpected ways. One of the main ways these impulses and our true personality can be converted or seep out is through something called projection. This is where we notice, we judge or we overact to something in someone else because of how it touches something unresolved in us. For example, we might see somebody posting a lot on Instagram and they look really hot and they're showing off the house they just bought and they're their accomplishments and they've achieved a lot. And our instinctual reaction is to kind of roll our eyes and to criticize them and to find something
愤怒、自私，它们依然存在。从某种意义上说，这就像能量。它不能被消灭，只能被转化。我们自我的这一部分会以意想不到的方式转化。这些冲动和我们的真实人格得以转化或渗透出来的主要途径之一，就是所谓的“投射”。这就是为什么我们会因为某事触动了我们内心未解的结，从而注意到、评判或者对别人的某事做出过度反应。例如，我们可能会看到有人在Instagram上频繁发帖，他们看起来很性感，在炫耀刚买的房子和他们的成就，他们取得了很大的成功。我们的本能反应是翻白眼、批评他们，并在那张照片中找出问题所在，
that is wrong with that picture and a reason why they are evil, awful and don't deserve it. Now, is this an issue with them or with us? Does their behavior actually impact us? No. But their confidence indirectly impacts us because we've internalized societal messages to do with humility and not showing off. And their confidence, their outwardness, feels unbearable to witness because it requires us to acknowledge that we would never feel comfortable enough doing that ourselves and that we are maybe missing out. Another example is becoming very irritated by someone who was very needy or sensitive. Yes, maybe it is annoying.
找出他们是邪恶的、糟糕的并且不配拥有这一切的理由。现在，这是他们的问题还是我们的问题？他们的行为真的影响到我们了吗？没有。但他们的自信间接地影响了我们，因为我们已经内化了与谦逊和不炫耀相关的社会信息。他们的自信、他们的外向让我们感到难以忍受，因为这迫使我们承认，我们自己永远不会觉得这样做足够舒适，并且我们可能错失了某些东西。另一个例子是，对非常黏人或敏感的人感到非常恼火。是的，也许这确实很烦人，
And maybe you don't want to look further into it. But shadow work would maybe take that sense of annoyance you have about something that doesn't really impact you and interrogate it and expand on it and say, well, you know, you've spent years and years denying your own needs and your own sensitivity that you think is shameful. So when you see it in somebody else, you see the alternative that you didn't have to suffer, that you didn't have to suppress, and you realize the burden that you've carried, and the only way to not feel terrible about the fact that you've carried that burden for so long is to dismiss that behavior in somebody else. Sometimes the size of our reaction to somebody else's actions and emotions and life is the greatest indicator that we've suppressed such a feeling in ourselves,
也许你不想深入去探究。但阴影工作会把这种对某种并不真正影响你的人事物所产生的恼火感拿出来，进行审视、展开剖析，并说道：“好吧，你知道的，你多年来一直在否定自己的需求和敏感，你认为这是羞耻的。”所以当你从别人身上看到这些时，你看到了另一种可能性：原来你本不必承受那些苦难，本不必去压抑，于是你意识到自己所背负的重担。而为了不去为自己背负了这么久的重担感到难过，唯一的办法就是贬低别人身上的那种行为。有时，我们对别人的行为、情绪和生活的反应程度，正是我们在自己身上压抑了这种情感的最大指标，
and we cannot come to terms with that. Another way our shadow self presents beyond our reactions to the behaviors of others is through repeated patterns of behavior that continuously lead to outcomes that we are not happy with. And yet, despite that, the behavior cannot be broken, it cannot be avoided. We keep doing it despite all of our best attempts. Cheating, lying, letting ourselves down are some big examples, but it can also be more subtle. A particularly familiar example of this is constantly choosing emotionally unavailable people
而我们无法接受这一点。除了对他人行为的反应之外，我们的阴影自我表现出来的另一种方式，是通过不断导致我们不满意的结果的重复行为模式。然而尽管如此，这种行为无法被打破，无法被避免。尽管我们做出了种种最大努力，我们还是不断地在重复。出轨、说谎、让自己失望是一些显着的例子，但它也可以表现得更微妙。一个特别熟悉的例子就是，不断选择情感上无法给予支持的人，
or people who are sincerely bad for you and not knowing why. And I say choosing because it often actually doesn't even feel like a choice. It just happens. It just always ends the same way. And you just for the life of you, you look around and you're like, how did I get here? I promised I wasn't going to do this again. I can't figure out why I always find myself in these situations.
或者是那些对你真心不好的人，却又不知道为什么。我说“选择”，是因为它通常甚至感觉不像是一个选择。它就是发生了。而且结果总是以同样的方式收场。你环顾四周，百思不得其解：“我怎么会落到这田地？我发誓我再也不这样了。我怎么总是陷入这种境地，我想不通。”
shadow work would see that pattern and know there is a hidden experience at at play. There is a deep belief perhaps that, you know, I'm not the kind of person who can ask for more or who deserves more than this because asking them to love me as I am is already too much. You know, there's a part of us that thinks that asking for anything more than the bad would be greedy and people who are greedy are bad people. people who are like me should just take what they can get. Or perhaps, you know, if I choose emotionally unavailable people, this type of love, you know, is the kind of love I can understand.
阴影工作会看穿这种模式，并知道背后隐藏着某种体验。也许存在一种根深蒂固的信念，即“我不是那种可以要求更多的人，或者说我不配得到比这更好的东西，因为要求他们按本来的样子爱我已经太过了”。你知道，我们内心的一部分认为，要求任何超过糟糕待遇的东西都是贪婪，而贪婪的人就是坏人。像我这样的人就应该逆来顺受，捞到什么算什么。或者也许，你知道的，如果我选择情感上无法给予支持的人，这种爱，你知道的，就是我能理解的爱。
And so if they leave me, it won't hurt as much because I knew they won't ever fully in it. It won't be as unexpected as an emotionally available person leaving me. And therefore, my ego can be protected. And the ugly parts of me that might come out during love will never have to come out. So these behaviours can exist in everything, literally everything, something, like anything. Anything that you continue to do that you're like, I don't like that I'm doing this and yet I can't stop. Anything that you like secretly just like without any warning, like hate and other people
因此，如果他们离开我，也不会那么痛苦，因为我知道他们从来没有完全投入。这不会像一个情感上健全的人离开我那样出乎意料。因此，我的自我（Ego）可以得到保护，我在爱中可能会暴露出来的那些丑陋部分也永远不必显露出来。所以这些行为可以存在于一切之中，字面意义上的万事万物，任何事情。任何你一直在做、却又觉得自己“讨厌自己这么做却又停不下来”的事情。任何你偷偷地、毫无预兆地去憎恨别人的事情，
is a big, big sign that the shadow is at play. The shadow is secretive. You know, the persona we can identify. We can kind of see the thing that's trying to cover everything else up. But the thing that's pulling the strings behind it requires a lot more effort to see. And it requires stepping beyond the ego and beyond the conscious mind. And particularly the self-conscious mind so that we can look into the danger zone and so that we can actually know ourselves. By coming to terms of the parts of ourselves we would rather not know.
都是阴影在起作用的巨大信号。阴影是隐秘的。你知道的，我们能够识别出人格面具。我们能够看到试图掩盖其他一切的事物。但是，在背后操纵这一切的事物需要花费更多的努力才能被看见。它需要超越自我（Ego）和意识层面，尤其是自我意识层面，这样我们才能深入危险区，从而真正了解自己。通过接受我们宁愿不知道的自我部分。
Now, you may be asking yourself, you know, Gemma, if our shadow, and our shadow self survives by being imperceivable, how do we perceive what doesn't want to be perceived? How can we see the shadow if the shadow doesn't want to be found? Well, we've known to this already, but the shadow self leaves clues. And we're going to talk about them after the short break. Behind every night spent making the kids lunches,
现在，你可能会问自己：“杰玛（Gemma），如果我们的阴影以及我们的阴影自我通过不被察觉而得以生存，我们该如何去感知那些不想被感知的东西呢？如果阴影不想被找到，我们又怎么能看到它呢？”好吧，我们对此已经有所了解了，阴影自我会留下线索。短暂休息之后，我们将讨论这些线索。在每天花时间为孩子们做午餐的背后，
there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pesto survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.orgia for details and to check availability.
有着许多悬念。他们会最终吃掉蔬菜吗？罗勒青酱能撑过第一口吗？饭盒带回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切完黄瓜之前，你能看完第8集吗？获取Bell纯光纤互联网，附带令人向往的Netflix和Disney Plus，每月只需94美元起。两年期互联网及自动扣款信用额度享有两年价格保证。访问bell.orgia了解详情并查询可用性。
Bell, connection is everything. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was something.
Bell，连接就是一切。当我14岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在理应毁灭他们的境遇中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特（Elizabeth Smart），这些是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边传来低沉、嘲弄的声音说：闭嘴，什么也别说。每周，我都会和经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问他会伤害我。我开始觉得有什么东西，
someone at the end of my bed and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters,
床头好像有个人，然后我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制并险些被剥夺发声的权利。但这些都不是关于被夺走的故事，而是关于为了活着逃出来需要付出什么的故事。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特主持的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这里是《Prose Society》，这是一档每周播出的播客，它既是读书俱乐部，也是针对思想女孩、
pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is the Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations,
流行文化痴迷者，以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等程度探讨的人的群聊。我是艾莉·拉洛（Eli Rallo），每周我们都在书籍、互联网以及每个人都在热烈讨论的话题之间建立联系。我得去查查这个故事。我太着迷了。我太着迷了。从畅销书作家和您最喜爱的图书创作者，到最新的流行文化时刻，一切皆有可能。这就好比如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的讯息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度剖析、聪明的流行文化对话，
or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook on the Big. money players network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what
还是寻找一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Prose Society》。书页之间，不见不散。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们在大钱玩家网络（Big Money Players network）主持播客节目《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。我们的节目对初次听众非常友好。每周我们都会与演艺界（也就是业内人士）的某个人交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们
they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman. Not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip this script? Okay. What is the surprise woman? Actually, you think. is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird. Adam Scott, ugh. This entire time you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to visit the show. I would never expect, I would never set expectations for something like that to happen.
能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，也没有人因为他们的公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多优秀的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman）。没那么优秀。其实，你能帮我重塑一下这个吗？我们何不反其道而行之，对吧？我们怎么不把这个剧本翻转过来？好吧。什么是惊喜女性？其实，你觉得。直男其实才是那个行为古怪的人。亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott），呃。你这一整天都一直在期待亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）来节目做客。我绝不会期待，我绝不会对这种事情发生抱有期望。
It seems like you did. If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm open to it. I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope. It's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? Like, you're like, oh, what's a state. Everyone's so dumb. And fake. Right. Fake and also not interested. Or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are
看来你确实抱有了。如果宇宙允许这样的事情发生，我是持开放态度的。我总是会接受的。你知道的，丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride），好吧。是的，这里散发着所有脆弱的男子气概。老实说，我走在走廊里就能闻到。我当时想：那是大麻吗？不。那是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），不。因为很多时候脱离了语境，人们根本不明白，甚至不知道什么是圈子。你知道我的意思吗？就像，哦，什么是州。每个人都好笨。
without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space. where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us.
而且很虚假。对。虚假而且漠不关心。或者只是像，哦，我有我自己的生活，我不在乎你的生活。还有很多其他的大人物，如果没有我们，他们
Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Shadow Work is freaking hard work.
就不会有今天的成就。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）亲自告诉我们他喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在太忙了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮涅罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行是因为这是一个罕见的空间，
Because what Shadow Work asks you to do is to notice irrational reactions, repeated patterns, anger, disappointment, resentment that seems to have no origin. It asks you to notice limiting and cruel beliefs, desires that become jealousy. It asks you to identify ways you keep self-sabotaging. And then it says, look at these parts of you that you wish you weren't and go backwards. Work backwards from here. Deconstruct the persona until you find what is underneath the mask. It basically puts us on this line of questioning which says, if I now know this part of me exists, it must exist for a reason, and often that reason is
在这里我可以对别人说“好”，而不需要先征求任何人的同意。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。每次我试图独自一人时，我总是会遇到人，他们会说：“你们对我笑了。
protection. What is my worst fear here? And when and why did I learn to be so afraid of it? And why am I so certain that it will happen? And therefore, why do I construct all these things around it to keep that locked away and to prevent it from ever occurring by acting out in ways, doing things that I don't necessarily want to do. Like we said, a lot of our encounters with the shadow do come from projection. Basically, you see something in someone else that you don't like. That says something about you. But it's so much easier to see the perceived flaws of others than ourselves. And so that strange hatred, that strange jealousy or fear or whatever it is, is pointing towards the shadow. Jung also believe that your dreams are a very important place to encounter the shadow. To him,
这里可没多少人笑。”正当你独自一人时，你对世界的接纳度才是最高的，你接受的是真实的世界，而不是别人兜售给你的谎言。这段时间可以让你突破极限、改变心意，或者唤醒一个全新的自己。所以，无论你是一位独自旅行的老手，还是正紧张得不敢预定第一次旅行，我都希望你在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。阴影工作真的是一份极其艰难的工作。因为阴影工作要求你去注意那些不理性的反应、重复的模式、愤怒、失望、似乎找不到根源的怨恨。它要求你去注意那些限制性的、残酷的信念，以及转变成嫉妒的欲望。它要求你找出自己不断进行自我破坏的方式。然后它告诉你：看着你身上那些你希望自己没有的部分，然后往回走。从这里开始倒推。解构你的人格面具，直到你发现面具之下的真相。它基本上把我们带入了这样一串问题：如果我现在知道我身上存在这一部分，它存在就一定有它的原因，而通常这个原因就是自我保护。我在这里最害怕的恐惧是什么？我是在什么时候、为什么学会对此如此恐惧的？为什么我如此确信它会发生？因此，为什么我要围绕它构建所有这些东西，通过做出我未必想做的事情、表现出某种行为，来把它锁起来，并防止它真的发生？正如我们所说，我们与阴影的许多遭遇确实来自于投射。基本上，你在别人身上看到了你不喜欢的东西。这说明了你的一些情况。但是，看到别人身上察觉到的缺点，可比看到我们自己身上的要容易得多。因此，那种奇怪的恨意、那种奇怪的嫉妒或恐惧，无论它是什么，都在指向阴影。荣格还认为，你的梦境是遭遇阴影的一个非常重要的场所。对他来说，
he did a lot of work on himself with this, but to him and to us, I think we know it. One of the only times, some of the only times that we are relaxed enough to encounter the things that we are suppressing or hiding is when we are literally asleep and our conscious brain can't come in and say, nope, don't think about that one. To him, a dream was never a dream. Ever. Ever. It was a sign. from your deep subconscious that required interrogation. In our dreams, you know, the shadow is often the same gender as the dreaming ego. And things happen that reveal what we secretly want and what we secretly don't like about ourselves.
他在这方面做了很多自我调整，但对我们和他的经历而言，我想我们都很清楚。我们能足够放松地去面对那些被压抑或隐藏的事物的时间屈指可数，其中之一就是当我们真正入睡、清醒的大脑无法介入并说“不，不要去想那个”的时候。对他来说，梦从来不是普通的梦。从来都不是。绝对不是。它是一个来自你深层潜意识的信号，需要被审视。在梦中，你知道，阴影通常与做梦时的自我具有相同的性别。事情的发生揭示了我们内心秘密的渴望以及我们私下里对自己不满意的地方。
So as I said, these moments are called encountering the shadow. Once we've encountered the shadow and we've kind of brushed up against these parts that we really are like, oh, I don't know if I like that. and myself. Only then can we actually begin to do something about it and can we begin to assimilate the shadow, assimilate the shadow, which is to say incorporate the shadow into our conscious awareness to create better fundamental self-awareness, thereby kind of providing a way for us to know ourselves even deeper. Now, in the words of Jung, the interrogation of the shadow or the realization of the personal unconscious and how it endeavors to influence us is like the task
正如我所说，这些时刻被称为遭遇阴影。一旦我们遇到了阴影，并且稍微接触到了这些让我们真正感到“哦，我不知道自己是否喜欢这样”的部分。只有到那时，我们才能真正开始采取行动，开始同化阴影，也就是把阴影融入我们的清醒意识中，从而建立更好的根本自我意识，进而为我们更深地了解自己提供一种途径。用荣格的话来说，对阴影的审视或对个人潜意识及其如何试图影响我们的认识，就像是一项任务
of a lifetime. It's ugly work, it's brutal work, it's messy work, it is absolutely essential. In his words, he basically said, the privilege of a lifetime is to become who you truly are. And only when you acknowledge the worst parts of yourself and the worst parts of humanity, can you say that you have done that? Can you say that you know who you are? The thing is, despite the shadow being seen as this reservoir of darkness and all the things we wish nobody knew, the shadow is also the seat of our creativity. And it's the seat of our ability to relate to the world and to relate to the best, but also the worst in others. Our shadow, also, finally enough, contains our potential. I don't think, I haven't mentioned this yet, but it's such a critical part of this.
一生之幸。这是一份丑陋的工作，残酷的工作，混乱的工作，但它绝对必不可少。用他的话来说，他基本上说过，一生的特权就是成为真正的自己。只有当你承认了自己最糟糕的部分和人性中最糟糕的部分时，你才能说你做到了这一点？你能说你了解自己是谁吗？问题是，尽管阴影被视为黑暗的蓄水池以及我们希望没有人知道的所有事情，但阴影也是我们创造力的所在地。它是我们与世界联系、与他人最好的一面以及最糟糕的一面联系的能力的所在地。有趣的是，我们的阴影最终也包含了我们的潜力。我不认为，我之前没提到过这一点，但这确实是其中至关重要的一部分。
there is this amazing article that was published by the Society of Analytical Psychology, and it talks about how the shadow contains all sorts of qualities, capacities and potential, which if not recognized and taken ownership over will mean that you maintain essentially a state of impoverishment within your personality. And you deprive yourself of your destiny, of a source of energy, of a bridge to connection, dreams. For example, a person might believe that to be assertive is to be selfish or arrogant. So they go through life being pushed around by others and deep down, seething with resentment. That in turn makes them feel guilty and that is an ugly part of themselves they don't want to
有一篇由分析心理学学会发表的精彩文章，它谈到了阴影如何包含各种品质、能力和潜力，如果不认识到这一点并对其承担责任，就意味着你的个性实际上将保持一种贫瘠的状态。你会剥夺自己的命运、能量的来源、通往联系和梦想的桥梁。例如，一个人可能认为自信就是自私或傲慢。所以他们一生都在被别人推来搡去，内心深处却在怨恨中沸腾。这反过来又让他们感到内疚，这是他们不愿谈论的自己丑陋的一部分。
talk about. They don't want to acknowledge that they have the capacity for these things, but therefore by not acknowledging that, they aren't able to use that to their advantage. The shadow needs to bring this stuff to the surface. It's also important to say this kind of of work can be really emotionally intense and painful. It often requires us to go back into childhood, to go back into our belief system and when we were taught that we weren't enough or that we couldn't do that, that part of us was ugly. And a lot of people talk about the pain of doing that as the whole point. The only way to confront these deep parts of yourself is to question the ego and question the persona and therefore, you know, challenge it, which is not going to like.
他们不想承认自己有能力做这些事情，因此，如果不承认这一点，他们就无法利用这一点来为自己谋利。阴影需要把这些东西带到表面上来。同样重要的是要说明，这种工作可能在情感上非常强烈且痛苦。它通常需要我们回到童年，回到我们的信仰系统，回到我们被教导说我们还不够好或者我们做不到的那段时期，当时我们觉得自己的那部分是丑陋的。许多人谈到这样做的痛苦时，认为这正是重点所在。对抗自己内心深处这些部分的唯一方法就是质疑自我和面具，从而，你知道的，去挑战它，这是它不会喜欢的。
some people can engage with these kind of gentle, reflective practices and they find them helpful. I've never been that person. And I probably never will be. And I think what the shadow, like shadow work really does is it says, let's take a freaking knife to that. Let's, let's just ripple this up and just like really get down into the dirt and wrestle with who I am so that I can be better for myself and for others. So it sounds quite violent. I think it psychologically is. And that's why I don't think, and neither did Jung. You didn't think that shadow work was for everyone. And I think there are certain situations where it can get us further detached from our true selves if we become obsessive, obsessive with all these things that we're
有些人可以参与这种温和的、反思性的练习，他们发现这些练习很有帮助。我从来都不是那种人。我可能也永远不会是。我认为阴影，就像阴影工作真正做的那样，它说，让我们对它动刀子吧。让我们，让我们彻底把它翻个底朝天，就像真正深入泥潭，与我是谁搏斗，这样我才能对自己和他人更好。所以这听起来相当暴力。我认为从心理学上讲确实如此。这就是为什么我认为，荣格也不认为。你并不认为阴影工作适合所有人。我认为在某些情况下，如果我们变得强迫性，对我们所做的所有事情都强迫性，它会让我们进一步远离真实的自我
doing because as much as it's important to interrogate our behavior, sometimes things are just random. Sometimes you just do things because that's just how you responded. And sometimes you just don't like people. Sometimes you just make mistakes. Sometimes you're unpleasant. It's just not any deeper than that. There is a difference between gently, as gently as you can, but attempting to meet a hidden part of yourself with no judgment, with the only goal to know yourself deeper, the good and the bad, and pursuing shadow work because you want to completely eradicate every single part, of you that is bad or awful or that is in your way. That is impossible. You, every single human, need these aspects of themselves. It is what balances us. It is who we are. It's what makes us
因为尽管审视我们的行为很重要，但有时事情只是随机发生的。有时你做一件事只是因为你的反应就是那样。有时你就是不喜欢某些人。有时你只是犯了错误。有时你就是很不讨人喜欢。事情其实没那么深奥。尽可能温和地试图毫无评判地面对自己隐藏的部分，其唯一的目的是更深入地了解自己，无论是好是坏；与为了完全根除你身上每一个不好、可怕或阻碍你的部分而进行阴影工作，这两者是有区别的。这是不可能的。你，每一个人，都需要自己身上这些方面。正是这些平衡了我们。这才是真正的我们。正是这些造就了我们的
difference. It's part of our human psychology. So there does come a point where over-interrogating your beliefs and your ideas about yourself and your bad behavior and your hidden self is is harmful. And I think it's harmful when we feel like everything needs to be seen through that explanation or when we just use it as a further way to shame ourselves. And shame is how you get here in the first place. Shame is how you get to a place where your identity and your personality and your mind has split. So working with a psychotherapist, I was going to say a psychologist, but a psychotherapist
不同。这是我们人类心理的一部分。所以确实会有一个时刻，过度审视你的信仰、你对自己的看法、你的不良行为以及你隐藏的自我会带来伤害。我认为，当我们觉得所有事情都需要通过这种解释来看待，或者当我们只是把它当作进一步羞辱自己的方式时，它就是有害的。而羞辱正是你走到这一步的原因。羞辱正是让你的身份、个性和心灵分裂的原因。所以与心理治疗师合作，我本想说心理学家，但专门与心理治疗师合作
specifically is what can really help you to do this safely and in a constructive way. psychotherapy, psychoanalytic therapy is a whole set, a whole discipline of psychology that just attempts to sit with the unconscious mind and the shadow, and it is informed by the work of Jung and Freud, and guess what, it's not for everyone. It's not for everyone, but if it is for you, having somebody who's trained in this can support you and just holding your experience, looking at it, allowing you to examine it without needing to get into that state of preoccupation. and it means that you can actually discover who you are rather than feeling overwhelmed
才是真正能帮助你安全且建设性地完成这一过程的方法。心理治疗，精神分析疗法是心理学的一个整体分支，一门学科，它只是试图与无意识的心灵和阴影共存，它受到荣格和弗洛伊德工作的启发，而且你猜怎么着，它并不适合所有人。它并不适合所有人，但如果它适合你，有一个受过这方面训练的人可以支持你，陪伴着你的经历，审视它，让你在不需要陷入全神贯注的状态下去检查它。这意味着你实际上可以发现你是谁，而不是感到被压倒
by a painful, painful list of insights that you just don't know how to deal with. And again, I want to say this. Like, it's not for everyone. Shadow work is not meant to be this endless excavation of your deepest, darkest feelings, the excavation of them and the removal of them. It's not meant to become a hobby of suspecting yourself
被痛苦不堪、不知该如何处理的深刻洞见清单所压垮。再说一次，我想说的是。这并不适合所有人。阴影工作并不是要成为对你内心最深处、最黑暗的情感进行无休止的挖掘、挖掘并将其移除。它不应该成为一种怀疑自己的爱好
or being suspicious of the deeper meaning behind your actions. The point is to acknowledge when your current patterns of feeling and behaving aren't working for you anymore and getting curious about how you can work through these with enough compassion that they don't control your life, but you acknowledge your capacity to have these parts of you. Rather than eliminating them, shadow work is about bringing them into conscious awareness with curiosity so that you can understand yourself better. and integration in this context means actually seeing these ugly sides of humanity and sides of you and not saying that's okay and not saying I completely approve of that but saying I get why I got there
或者对你行为背后的更深层意义起疑心。重点是承认你当前的情感和行为模式不再对你起作用，并开始好奇你如何才能以足够的同情心来解决这些问题，让它们不再控制你的生活，而你承认自己有能力拥有这些部分。阴影工作不是消除它们，而是带着好奇心将它们带入有意识的觉知中，这样你就能更好地了解自己。在这种情况下，整合意味着真正看到人性中这些丑陋的一面以及你身上的某些面，而不是说这没关系，也不是说我完全赞同这一点，而是说我明白我为什么会走到这一步
and I get why I was ashamed of that and I get why society doesn't like this but also if I don't want this to influence my behavior in poor ways I have to be able to sit with this and acknowledge that this is just part of who I am and I think that's why a lot of people seek out shadow work because they are tired of repeating the same pattern of behavior and not understanding why they're doing it and their only way of counteracting it being shame and fear and suppression. They just want a more holistic understanding of their identity. But be prepared to find things that you don't want to find that have been buried, buried, buried, buried, buried, and it's not the treasure kind of buried. Or maybe it is, depending on how you see it.
我明白我为什么为此感到羞耻，我明白为什么社会不喜欢这样，但同时，如果我不想让这以糟糕的方式影响我的行为，我必须能够接受这一点并承认这只是我的一部分。我想这就是为什么很多人寻求阴影工作，因为他们厌倦了重复相同的行为模式，却不明白自己为什么这么做，而他们唯一对抗它的方式就是羞耻、恐惧和压抑。他们只是想要对自己的身份有更全面的理解。但要做好准备，去发现那些你不想找到的、被深深埋葬的东西，而且不是那种寻宝式的埋葬。或者也许是的，这取决于你怎么看。
but it's not going to be fun to be like, oh, this thing and the reason I'm not behaving the way that I want to, and the reason that all these things have happened in my life is because of this deep wound or this deep thing that I've suppressed. So be prepared for that. Also, be mindful not to start doing that same level of interrogation for other people and psychoanalizing everything they do or say just because you've gotten some basic idea of shadow work and psychoanalytical psychology. how other people's shadow is projected is actually quite frankly none of your business unless what they do activates your own shadow in which case that is of your concern but it is only what you have ownership over that you can be that i think you can pass judgment on or that you can you know psychoanalyze or explain so as we wrap up i want to recommend a few other
但这绝对不会让人觉得有趣，比如，哦，原来这件事，以及我没有表现出我想要的样子，我在生活中发生的所有这些事情的原因，都是因为这个深深的创伤或我压抑的深刻东西。所以要为此做好准备。同时，要注意不要开始对其他人进行同等程度的审视，不要仅仅因为你对阴影工作和精神分析心理学有了某种基本的了解，就去精神分析他们所做的或所说的一切。坦率地说，别人的阴影是如何投射的，根本不管你的事，除非他们的行为激活了你自己的阴影，在这种情况下，那是你关心的事情，但只有你拥有所有权的东西，你才能对之评判，或者你才能（你知道的）进行精神分析或解释。所以在我们结束之际，我想推荐一些其他的
resources there's only so much we can do in a 30 minute episode i hope i've covered the basics for you. If you want to go further, the book meeting the shadow is so good. It will, when I read it, I would read like a passage and then I'd have to sit in silence for like five minutes. It took me a while to finish it. I read it a couple years ago. It's great, though. It's like the best guide other than Carl Jung's original works, obviously, on this topic. And they also have exercises in there as well. And then there is a video on the YouTube channel eternalized, which I used to love, love, love when I was in high school. And the video is called The Shadow Carl Jung's Warning to the World. That is just amazing. And he breaks down the personal
资源。在30分钟的单集里我们能做的事情有限，我希望我已经为你讲了基础知识。如果你想深入了解，那本《与阴影相遇》（Meeting the Shadow）太棒了。它会，当我读的时候，我会读一段，然后我就必须沉默坐上五分钟左右。我花了一段时间才读完它。我几年前读的。不过真的很棒。除了卡尔·荣格的原著之外，这显然是关于这个主题最好的指南。里面也有一些练习。然后YouTube频道《Eternalized》上有一个视频，我在高中时非常非常喜欢。那个视频叫《阴影：卡尔·荣格对世界的警告》（The Shadow: Carl Jung's Warning to the World）。那简直太棒了。他剖析了个体
shadow. He also breaks down the collective shadow a little bit more. But what he really gets into is that this core idea, the journey of a lifetime is to know oneself. And you have to be able to sit with the ugly parts of oneself in order to do that and to understand why you don't have the life that you want and how to get there. So I'm going to leave some little descriptions, oh, leave the link, sorry, in the description to those below. I hope you've enjoyed this episode. I hope it's brought you some more knowledge.
阴影。他还稍微剖析了一下集体阴影。但他真正深入探讨的是这个核心理念，人生的旅程就是认识自己。为了做到这一点，你必须能够接受自己丑陋的部分，并理解为什么你没有过上你想要的生活以及如何实现它。所以我会在下方的描述中留一些小说明，哦，留下链接，抱歉。希望你喜欢这一集。希望它给你带来了更多知识。
Thank you to our research and Libby Corbett for her assistance with this episode. A reminder, you can follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Make sure that you are following along or subscribe so that you get notified when new episodes are released and you have something to listen to on your Monday morning commute or on your Saturday, Sunday morning runs. What else do I need to say? All the usual stuff. All the usual stuff.
感谢我们的研究人员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Corbett）对本集节目的协助。提醒一下，你可以在Instagram上关注我们：That Psychology Podcast。确保你进行了关注或订阅，这样当新节目发布时你就会收到通知，并且在周一早上的通勤路上或周六、周日早上的跑步中有些东西可以听。我还得说些什么？所有老一套的内容。所有老一套的内容。
You can watch us on Netflix. But yeah, you can watch episodes, not like this one, but all of our other episodes on Netflix. This is a special bonus episode. So they're just for my audio only fans, but you can watch other episodes on Netflix. And you can just find everything else that we're up to in the description. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Be kind and gentle to your shadow. We will talk very, very soon.
你可以在Netflix上观看我们。不过是的，你可以观看节目，不是像这一集这样，而是我们在Netflix上的所有其他节目。这是一集特别的加长版节目。所以它们只适合我的纯音频粉丝，但你可以在Netflix上观看其他节目。你可以在简介中找到我们正在做的其他所有事情。但直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己好一点。对你的阴影也要善良和温和。我们很快就会再聊。
I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the I-Hearton. radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home.
我在被俘期间幸存了九个月，我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在理应摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特（Elizabeth Smart），这些是幸存者档案。每周，我都会和那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，且险些被灭口。这些故事讲述了活着逃脱所需要付出的代价。在I-Heart-Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。
Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the Eye. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Pro Society每周播客兼具读书俱乐部和群聊功能，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》具有同等讨论价值的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、图书交谈创作者以及大量过度思考的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴联系起来。是的，我着迷了。我太着迷了。在I-Heart-Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Pro Society。
I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotvey. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the I. I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman.
我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotbby），播客《霍达·科特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby）的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）向有抱负的演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供建议时那样。你被雇用不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇用是为了用你自己填满这个空间。在I-Heart-Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听霍达·科特比的《快乐101》。
I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity. for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport and Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Each week, we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they
在新播客《独自一人》（Solita）中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的私密空间，我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。在I-Heart-Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《独自一人》。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）和肖恩·克莱門茨（Sean Clements）。我们主持播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。每周，我们都会与业内人士交谈，试图帮助他们的事业，看看他们
have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stiller, and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为公关人员让他们上我们的节目而对他们生气。我们邀请了很多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·舍曼（Sarah Sherman）、亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）、丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）、本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），以及许多如果没有我们就不可能有今天成就的大人物。在I-Heart-Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。这是一档IHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。